case viewer at c-span dot-org our fax
number is two zero two seven three seven
three three two three and if you'd like
to send a card or letter our mailing
address is 400 North Capitol Street
Northwest suite 650 Washington DC the
zip code two zero zero zero one
next a discussion on crime education and
the federal budget a forum held today by
Laszlo and associates a political
consulting firm this event runs about an
hour in ten minutes
hello and welcome to our panel I'm
Jennifer Laszlo from Durham North
Carolina and I'm a reporter and
political columnist for The Daily Record
in Angier and Benson and done in
Lillington and other parts and I'm also
the president and founder of Laszlo and
associates a political training firm and
event management firm and I'm really
really excited to have our panel with us
today and I want to mention actually
that this panel is the idea of a c-span
viewer who called me after a panel and
said why is it that there are so few
women talking about politics on
television and really asked me to put
together a panel of the best and
brightest women in politics and I am
just really honored that each of you
have joined me today I'm really looking
forward to this discussion and want to
introduce each of our panelists before
we start with a couple of questions and
we will be taking questions from the
audience here with us today our first
panelist is Kim alfano
who is a republican media consultant and
I actually do want to mention because
last night I was watching equal time and
Mary Matlin was on talking about how
there are so few women media consultants
in the Republican Party and she thought
that they were none well indeed there
there is one it's Kim alfono and she's
terrific her clients are not only the
governor of Oklahoma but also
congressman JC Watts
and she is the winner of the 1994 rising
star award from campaigns and elections
magazine she is also a three-time poly
Award winner for her creativity and her
effectiveness in media our second
panelist Kelly Ann Fitzpatrick who is
not only a distinguished pollster but
she is also an attorney is had worked
very very much on the contract with
America she also was a pollster working
with Ronald Reagan and Jack Kemp she's
been featured recently by National
Journal as one of Washington's most
influential conservative age 40 and
younger our third panelist
and I think that we're out of
alphabetical order is April Lasseter who
is the communications and policy advisor
to Majority Whip Tom DeLay and I do want
to point out that she is speaking on her
own behalf not on behalf of the
congressman previously she served the
Honorable William R Archer
in the Bush administration for empower
America and the Family Research Council
she's also a weekly panelist on the
television show young bloods and has
appeared on any teased American family
and direct line
Christine Matthews is the founder and
president of cm research she formerly
served as vice president of public
opinion strategies which is obviously
one of America's largest polling firms
and I'm really excited that she broke
out and started her own operation her
past clients have it included senator
William cone the National Republican
Senatorial Committee and the Corporation
for Public Broadcasting she also serves
on the board of renew which is the
Republican Network to elect women and
previously served the Republican Party
of Indiana where she was the party's
campaign director for 105 mayoral
candidates Dianne who is our sole
democratic representative on the panel
today will be I'm sure holding her own
quite effectively she is the press
secretary for the Democratic National
Committee prior to that she served as
the press secretary to Senator Jim
Sasser of Tennessee and she was also the
spokesperson for the Senate Budget
Committee so she knows an awful lot
about the budget she was also in the
past the press secretary for congressman
sander Levin director of public affairs
for the National Federation of business
and professional women women our final
panelist Ann ston who I'm sure you've
all seen quite a bit on these panels and
on c-span and other television networks
as well is the founder and president of
one of America's largest and most
important Direct Mail fundraising
outfits she has worked on more than 300
presidential excuse me political
campaigns very very very effective
fundraiser she herself is a former
candidate for public office and is
active on several boards and nonprofits
Alexandria Virginia I'm gonna start
talking on this panel about crimes on
last night's news I was watching as they
reported that violent crime in America
has gone down it has actually gone down
by five percent and this statistic shows
that has gone down three years in a row
which is ironic because people are so
upset about crime and obviously people
feel very unsecure in their homes our
nation has the highest incarceration
rate of indeed any industrialized nation
we currently have 1.2 million people
serving prison sentences in America
today at an average cost of $25,000 per
prisoner the prison population in our
nation has doubled and redoubled again
in the last two decades and ironically
and unfortunately all our makers have
been inconsistent in how they've made
our laws so that the average murderer in
our country serves only six and a half
years in jail while the typical drug
offender stays in jail for 17 years
federal state local governments will
spend 30 billion dollars on Corrections
this year alone and spending on prison
construction has increased 612 percent
from 1979 to 1990 I'm gonna start
talking about crime because obviously
this is the most important issue to most
Americans and I'm gonna start talking
about it in the context of Oklahoma
we're clearly one of the greatest crimes
against people in our country was
recently committed Kim you are the media
consultant to the governor there what is
it like to be the leader of a state when
a great tragedy such as this takes place
and how does a leader communicate about
crime and security in such a time of
crisis well I guess I could I can't
really imagine what it would be like to
be the leader obviously that's not me
and and
and at that point you'd have to be frank
eating to discuss that but I'd say that
what was really eye-opening about that
that bombing was that nobody Frank
Keating when he ran for office was so
prepared I mean if you look at Frank
Keating's background he was an FBI agent
a US Attorney he was you know we said in
our commercials one of America's top
cops he had a background as a leader in
the state Senate in the State House and
this huge occurrence happened and this
this devastation happened in Oklahoma
and there he was he kind of was poised
and ready for it in fact I mean if you
could say that
religiously maybe that God tests people
perhaps they test the ones that are
prepared and I think that um that was
what was most breathtaking about the way
Oklahoma dealt with that situation he
was there he was a leader he spoke
clearly concisely he knew exactly what
needed to be done when it needed to be
done his background came forward he was
really prepared to handle it but not
just Frank Keating the entire state the
entire state just sort of lept
into action they were telling me some
stories about how once they started to
clean up after the bomb that
porta-potties were just kind of showing
up on the streets nobody knew where they
came from that boards truckloads of
boards showed up on the street from Home
Depot in a bunch of different stores
nobody paid for them none of the money
you know the cost of plywood did not go
up and people boarded up windows and
things just started happening it was
kind of this if ever there was a place
that was prepared for something like
that if you could never be prepared for
something like that it was Oklahoma and
I think leadership in that situation and
how you deal with media and how you
speak to people is just I think through
honesty and confidence and there is no
one who has more honest or more
confident than Frank Keating he just
really knew what he was doing knew what
he had to do pulled back down into his
soul and found you know his moral fiber
and said we need to hold hands get
together pray a lot and make things
happen and we need to do it for the sake
of family so I think he handled it at
honestly and almost almost innately you
know and maybe if it was someone else
they wouldn't be prepared the lesson I
gathered from that was you darn well
better know who your candidates are
because never have I had I thought my
two biggest races as a you know as a
sort of novice media consultant that
they'd be tested so dramatically and I
thank God that they were so prepared you
know I could I don't know I could not
imagine watching television and seeing
those guys if I if I had thought they
weren't up to the standard and they
really did a fantastic job is a great
lesson as a new media consultant and
let's go say Kim I think you pointed out
something that goes to the heart of
crime in this country and why perhaps
places like Oklahoma don't have as high
a crime rate as some of the urban areas
and really something that is at the
heart of how we solve the crime problem
in this country I think about what you
said about how people leptin to action
about how things appeared as if you know
from nowhere
people pulled together that was an
example of a community that was attached
okay
people attached to each other people
acting neighbors helping neighbors and
think about so many areas of this
country where people are not attached to
their communities where they're detached
and no offense to the media present here
but I think a lot of it does speak to
the problems created out of the media
and out of the fact that we all have
these electronic boxes in our homes and
we've become detached from each other we
don't have to get out into our community
to participate anymore we participate
with a box we don't have to get out into
our community to find out what's going
on we can turn on the television at
night and find out and I think that has
over the years this medium has helped
detach people and keep people from being
as much a part of the community as they
used to be unlike Oklahoma that is not
typical all over the country it isn't in
some of the more rural areas but this is
something I think we need to do more of
is to find the secret of the people of
Oklahoma and how they stay attached to
their community and try to replicate
this and I think only then are we really
going to get at the base cause of crime
and all the other things we do
incarceration at all is only going to be
treating the symptoms and not not
treating the root cause of why crime is
it has continues to be a problem in this
country Kellyanne I see you wanted to
jump in and then I'm going to turn to
the other side because I want to hear
from everyone on this topic it's a very
important topic and I think my
colleagues to the left and the right of
me touch upon from a polling perspective
what is very significant about crime
Oklahoma City the tragedy in Oklahoma
City is probably the large-scale
exemplification of how Americans really
perceive the crime problem in this
country it's a very personal issue and
that's why statistics like violent crime
has decreased 5% for the third year in a
row don't hold much water in in many of
our rural communities in many of the
places where communities are attached to
each other because those sort of
statistics about a systemic issue and
people when they think of crime they're
not concerned about crime as a system
issue and many politicians and many
office holders and many people in our
respective industries do missplay the
issue that way crime is a matter of
personal security and the crime bill
1994 will ultimately fail individual by
individual in their minds for the same
reason it was unpopular at the time it
was being debated and that's because it
didn't reach out to someone as an
individual and say I'm going to make you
feel safer in your home in your schools
and in your workplace it talked about
prison reforms which many people don't
believe even existing there talked about
midnight basketball and arts and crafts
and if in August of this year
the one-year anniversary of President
Clinton signing the crime bill if you
can't answer the question in the
affirmative that you feel safer the
crime bill means nothing to you as a
personal issue
it's not about system it's about
individual security during the
president's numbers or his poll numbers
went up significantly after the Oklahoma
bombing because of the way in which he
responded to that how have you looked as
the at the DNC at communicating on crime
and security issues overall well as we
as Kim spoke about the important issue
here was leadership and the governor of
Oklahoma did show excellent leadership
as did President Clinton and I think one
of the things that Americans like to see
is a Republican and Democrat in that
case working together to help the people
and to to bring aid in and to rebuild
the devis
community it was a horrible horrible
tragedy and it was perpetrated against
the federal government according to
newspaper reports and I think it's
important to kind of break that down and
look at what what is the federal
government but the the woman whose child
is in a daycare center who's doing her
job and helping seniors get their
Medicare benefits or another federal
worker who's helping a veteran get their
veterans benefits I think it's important
to look at the human face of this
tragedy and I think if anything possibly
good can come out of it it is a
discussion about where we are in this
country in terms of crime and fighting
crime and what causes this kind of
terrible event to occur and I think one
of the things that we have to look at
and I think the president spoke very
eloquently about this was that the
hateful speech that goes on in this
country on talk radio and in other
places and I think that fuels on this
kind of activity so I think that the
tragedy in Oklahoma sparked a discussion
about this and I think that'll be useful
for the country I wanted to make one
other point about the crime bill was a
significant piece of legislation passed
at the end of the 94 congressional
session and the crime bill contained a
lot of important provisions in it and I
think that there was a lot of talk about
midnight basketball which President Bush
actually endorsed as a point of light
when he was president but the crime bill
contained a three strikes and you're out
provision it contained money for
building new prisons it contained a
provision to put a hundred thousand new
police officers on the street I think
there's nothing that can go further
toward toward people's feeling about
their own personal safety is to see
police officers actually on the streets
patrolling in neighborhoods so there
were
very important things in the crime bill
the Violence Against Women Act was also
in the crime bill and so I think it's
easy to kind of sort of write it off and
say oh this was pork but if you really
take a close look at it there were a lot
of important programs in the crime bill
that will help people feel safer in
their homes and in their neighborhoods
and in their communities April when you
take a look at the crime issue and
legislation is moving and then you have
a whole conversation about the National
Rifle Association how do you take a look
at some of the gun legislation visa vie
crime and really talk about security
well the issues are definitely related
Jennifer the 1994 crime bill was
definitely filled with with pork
affectionately disagree with my neighbor
here the midnight basketball that
President Bush endorsed as a point of
light was actually privately funded
certainly we do need privately funded
involvement in our communities the
breakdown of the community can be
directly related to the sense of fear
about crime and about gun related
violence but I think the crime issue is
is very similar to the gun issue in that
it's really based on as Kellyanne was
saying how people feel Robert Samuelson
did a wonderful article last year called
the triumphs of psycho fact in which he
explained that it doesn't matter what is
true it matters what people feel is true
if people feel that guns are a problem
then they're going to be anti-gun and
yet there's no evidence to show that
stricter gun control laws make our
country any safer as we know living in
the murder capital of the world here we
have the strictest gun control laws in
Washington DC anywhere and we haven't
seen any benefits from that as far as
the crime bill in 94 as opposed to the
crime bill that was passed in the
contract with America I think what the
Congress is saying in response to what
the people are saying are we know in our
localities in our communities in our
states how we need to deal with our
crime issue some people don't need more
police on the streets some people need
fax machine
some people need more cars for their
policemen what we're trying to trying to
do this is consistent with the general
philosophy and with the contract with
America is to say you know best how to
spend the money we're not going to tell
you that you and your community need
more arts and crafts so that you need
more police necessarily we want to free
you up to say to evaluate your needs and
be responsive to the specific community
actually the news interestingly enough
said much the surprise of many that the
murder rate in the District of Columbia
was down 17 percent this year over last
year but it's very clear that the
perception that people have about
security doesn't reflect their feeling
that they're 17 percent less likely to
get murdered in the District of Columbia
this year than last year so I hear
exactly what you're saying
Christine I'd like to ask you as a
pollster who listens to a lot of you
know focus groups and a lot of the
answers to surveys how you talk to
candidates about conveying really a
sense of security and how you ask them
to then implement what they have
promised through their legislation what
I'd like to do first is go to a
different point of departure as I was
hearing all the debate on the whole
issue of crime I think it's really
important that we not try and extract
the issue of crime from the whole kind
of larger issue of the moral and
cultural decline and the decline in
values I mean we're seeing that people
are very very concerned about about that
type of issue and crime I think should
be effectively viewed in that context
because perception is everything and
even though crime actually is decreasing
what we're seeing as and discussed on
the medium that we're watching every
night the television is we're seeing
violent crime we're seeing horrible
things happening in society the Oklahoma
City bombing all sorts of kind of
atrocious crimes and I think that you
can say factually you know crime is
actually decreasing but there is a very
strong sense that within that context
that the moral fiber is really
absolutely unraveling and so you can do
specific you can address the specific
crime issue you can build more prisons
you can put more police on the street
but until and so people are supportive
of that I mean obviously throw something
at it do something
but until you absolutely address kind of
the larger issue of why is our society
behaving like this what's wrong why
aren't we treating each other with
respect then I think that you're not
going to be able to find any kind of
solution to the crime issue until you
kind of talk about it within that larger
context obviously we can talk about
crime to get forever but I want to move
on to our next topic quickly which is
sure actually I there's a debate going
on whether the federal government should
be funding a hundred thousand new police
officers or whether that money should be
just turned over to the states to do as
they wish I just want to respond to what
was said earlier and say that I think
people are going to feel more safer if
they're more police on the street than
if there are more fax machines in the
offices I think that goes a long way
toward people's perception about crime
and their own safety as well as the
reality of how safe they and their
families are on their streets so we the
Democrats are trying to protect that
provision in the crime bill because we
see that as one of the most important
aspects of fighting crime
thanks we're gonna move on to education
because also on the news they said that
the SAT scores the average SAT scores in
our country have gone up 100 points 100
points per child but unfortunately
that's because they're grading easier
than ever they have started to grade
upwards to give people an easier
advantage because unfortunately our SAT
scores have dropped so dramatically so I
want to ask our panelists to really
address the education issue because you
don't hear politicians or elected
officials talking or at least as much as
I would be interested in hearing about
education at all what should be done
what can be done what will be done let's
actually start with Christine because I
know you've done some work on some of
the vouchers and whatnot in the past or
different kinds of initiatives in
different ways of looking at how to
solve the crime proxies me the education
problem which obviously seems to be
linked to some extent to the crime
problem in terms of you know people
without a good education really
have much of a future I think education
is a lot like government um people are
willing to pay more money if they feel
like they're gonna get a good payoff or
have a good investment on their services
but what what they're finding is that
they're not having a very good
investment in terms of their tax dollars
that are going to education I mean the
outcomes are as you discussed I mean the
SATs scores are lower new businesses are
saying that people who graduate even
from college aren't able to write
effectively communicate effectively and
so we're really not having the kind of
outcomes that we want I have not
actually done a lot of polling on this
particular issue but I mean I think that
certainly this is a very key issue next
to crime and the public supports more
being done for education means you see
it I mean more money for crime more
money for education this is a very big
concern this is a very big concern
especially from women especially for
Republican Women and I think the
Republicans need to communicate a little
bit better to Republican Women in all
women on this issue on education so
April well it's it's an interesting
topic in light of the fact that our
buzzed budget resolution eliminates or
at least consolidates the Department of
Education I might be curious to know if
anyone can you know any of our viewers
really know what the Department of
Education does I had to do some reach
research on that for myself certainly
the Department of Education is very
similar to the to the federal government
when you talk about taking taxpayer
money and sending it up through levels
of bureaucracy and sending it back to
the schools you're always getting I
think less of a return for your
investment especially when we know that
school systems are most effective when
they are when they are locally
controlled and so I think that the
Republicans are talking about again
returning local control to the school
communities I think part of the reason
that education has not fared better over
the past I guess 20 years since we since
we saw that a nation at risk published
is that families again are less involved
in the schooling system we are seeing a
breakdown of the community we don't have
parents coming to PTA meetings or
tracking their children's progress in
schools and as a result the schools are
overburdened I mean we have
psychologists
in schools now we have school-based
clinics handing out condoms in schools
we have the school system trying to take
over the role that the family once did
and that simply will not be a successful
endeavor I agree with much of what's
been said so far that education excuse
me is a terribly important issue to to
people across this country it it affects
their income levels it affects their
family's economic stability and our goal
should be to make our educational system
as strong as it can be and make it as
effective and available to as many
people especially higher education with
respect to access I think it's important
to note that we are in a major fight
these days about what kind of federal
spending is going to occur with respect
to education the Republicans would like
to cut back one third of the funding the
federal funding that's spent on
education now this is not just a matter
of cutting some faceless bureaucrats out
of the Education Department what we're
talking about here are proposed cuts in
Head Start in school lunches in programs
to bring computers and educational
technology to schools in programs that
help disabled students and ironically we
were just talking about crime the
Republicans want to cut programs to to
make schools safe and drug-free so you
know there's a very real difference of
opinion I think most people do agree
that education historically and and
continues to be a more locally should be
run by by local and state officials
rather than the federal government but I
think that there is a role for the
federal government and I think when you
talk about making draconian cuts in
student loans and may
in college much less available for
students I think you're going to see a
big outcry across this country that this
isn't the way the country wants to go
first I think it was Newt Gingrich that
said only in Washington can a can
spending increase be called a cut in
fact the Republicans are cutting the
rate of increase but all the budgets on
education are going up and also block
grants are being called cuts but they
aren't it's just turning it back to the
local areas where it can be spent better
but I want to take a little different
tack because when I was a candidate for
mayor of Alexandria Virginia I learned a
lot about the way education shouldn't
happen and Alexandria for those of you
who don't know spends over $9,000 per
student in public education
we had the lhari had the highest
spending rate in the state and the
lowest for it the lowest scores for it
and in looking at it and looking at what
is the problem here it became readily
apparent that money more money for
education is definitely not the answer
in this country that is not the problem
in most areas of the country we are
spending a tremendous amount on our
students problem is the allocation of
the money we're getting away from basics
money's being taken out of the basics of
reading writing arithmetic and put into
other areas and into administration
there's many more levels of bureaucracy
in the school systems even at the local
level then we used to have another
biggie and this has nothing to do with
money we have lowered our expectations
you know you touched on it in the fact
that the scoring for SATs has gotten
easier but it's even more than that it
is really very sad especially for the
most disadvantaged students the
expectations for those students has been
dramatically lowered in Alexandria I had
occasion to be visited by school board
member who was very angry that I was
criticizing the school system and the
way money was being spent and he came to
visit and through a journal at me that
this child had written should read this
and you'll understand what the problem
is you just don't understand what these
teachers are dealing with so I read this
story and the story was written by this
child his name is Jose and he wrote my
name is Jose so-and-so and my daddy's
name is so-and-so
daddy we want to thank you for a
wonderful Christmas we had presents we
had a tree we had a wonderful dinner
thank you very much and that went on to
say my daddy is not with us anymore he's
going to Jesus but daddy mom and I want
you to know we thank you very much for a
wonderful Christmas and I said I read
the story and I said yeah he said see
see that's what they have to deal with I
said excuse me what well his father od'd
after Christmas I said yeah he said well
that's what they have to deal with I
said wait wait wait wait are you saying
there's a problem with this child his
wonderful memories about his father
he clearly has come through a trauma
with his head on straight
and he's got a wonderful optimistic
attitude about everything are you saying
there's a problem I said I'll tell you
you're the problem you've got a cultural
bias and what I found when I looked into
it especially in our local area was
people had a very maternal istic
paternalistic towards the disadvantaged
in the system had lowered expectations
and had the feeling of oh these poor
things they're never quite going to be
able to do it so we'll have to take care
of them and make allowances and I heard
from teachers within the system that you
know a lot of the teachers didn't have
tough enough standards and they weren't
holding the kids to higher standards and
that alone is a problem there was a
great editorial truly a landmark
editorial in the Wall Street Journal
earlier this week talking about Asian
students and looking at it Berkeley
because it was a controversy because
there's such a high percentage of Asians
as opposed to other different ethnic
classes and they said why is this that
they're excelling and being accepted at
such a high rate and they talked about
parents and they talked about the fact
that in the Asian culture and even after
they've been in this country for several
generations within their culture they
hold their children to an extremely high
standard the parents are very engaged in
what they're doing and they expect a lot
and they get a lot it isn't a matter of
their brains are different and somehow
they function better
it's a matter in their community
education is put first and we see that
in other cultures as well and I'll tell
you if we want to be competitive we've
got to reinstall that in all of the
different ethnic groups that make up
this American culture and that's how
you're going to restore education in
this country not with more money we got
to start more basic than that individual
kelly-ann what do you think the the role
of the federal government should be in
education and in raising standards for
education I'll speak as a pollster I'll
tell you what Americans are thinking on
that and actually have done a
significant amount of polling on
education and polling and focus groups
that matter on education and school
choice and the like and what's
interesting as upholsterers education
may be among the most fascinating issues
with which I deal but also one of the
most frustrating to communicate to
elected officials or to policymakers who
are interested to know what the public
opinion background on education is and
the answer is is twofold the first is at
a time when people are looking for a
streamlined federal government there is
a slim majority of support for
abolishing the Department of Education
and that is because many people are not
looking at just the style the term the
form Department of Education looking at
the function and they don't like what
they see there or at least they feel
confused they say well Johnny's fourth
grade teacher is okay my kids are
getting good grades what is this federal
Department of Education in Washington DC
which I hate for every other reason in
Washington and I visited once on a bus
tour so they don't they believe that
education is a very local not even state
as much as local issue that when you are
dealing with the children of this
country you've got to have the closest
proximity to the decision-makers as you
possibly can
and what's happening is parents and
teachers are pointing the fingers at
each other and of the PTA which once was
a mainstay in our society
I think the Association part the a of
the PTA is really what's missing now
that parents and teachers are not bound
together in working for children
education as a polling issue is a
sleeper concern it's a sleeper issue and
what I mean by that is if you ask top of
the mind responses what is the number
one problem facing this country today
people quickly talk about crime or the
economy or for a while last year health
care whatever they're hearing on the
news pretty much there isn't a lot of
press coverage on education as a front
line story if you haven't noticed but
when you ask people you give them either
a series of five is
Jews and education is one of them you
say I'm now going to read you a list of
issues which one do you believe should
be top priority for President Clinton in
the Congress and if you say some of
those top ones that come out top of mind
response health care welfare crime the
economy but you add education their
education almost always peaks at between
28 and 31 percent so it's when you're
reminding people education is an
important issue they immediately latch
onto it a better example of that
research-wise is I cannot walk into a
focus group of any type of cross section
of America today designed to talk about
any issue without hearing about
education in the first two to three
minutes whenever I start talking in
general terms of what's on your mind
what do you think Washington can do
better what is your number one concern
locally what is your number-one concern
nationally I always hear about education
because Jennifer and you touched on this
education is viewed as both the lack of
education and the lack of priority that
we all give it as a nation is viewed as
the symptomatic of all the problems but
it's also used it's also viewed as the
best solution that better education if
we invest in our youth as resource and
stop using them as a sort of media ploys
between our we cutting head start are we
cutting school lunches if we really
concentrate on our children and the
value that they have in the future that
they give us then education in fact is a
very important issue there's a real
pro-family climate in the Congress now
that has led to a lot of the pieces of
legislation that both been passed as
part of the contract with American that
are currently being marked up and
debated and this profoundly climate is a
perfect one to reintroduce education as
a tremendous priority school choice
vouchers are very popular even though
prop 174 failed 2 to 1 in California
that was really it I'll defer to our
media expert there was really a media
successes of public relations coup as an
issue school choice vouchers are a big
homerun
particularly with parents who feel that
last they'll be granted more control
over what their children are reading
where they're going to school who their
teachers are and school choice vouchers
equal control that's the same reason
people want education D federalized and
brought down to the local level it's the
same reason people like medical savings
accounts for
Healthcare and Medicare because it's
about personal control over what you're
doing what you're spending and
ultimately what your children are
reading in most states in this country
right now parents are not made privy
they do not have a right to have access
to the library books their children have
taken out of a library there's something
wrong with that I'm gonna get to
probably something along the lines of
what Anne said which was she touched at
the very end on personal responsibility
I think it's a question of discipline
education I don't know if anybody saw
day one last night but there was this
great five minute package on how in
North Carolina and in South Carolina
they're taking the problem children out
of schools and movement removing them
from classrooms and putting them in
special classrooms and letting kids
learn again and what was interesting
about that it's not a study by far but
what was interesting about that was the
kids that were left were saying it was
nice my grades went up it was nice to be
able to hear myself think it was nice to
be able to study yeah I'll tell on the
kid because I want my classroom to be
like it was somebody paid attention to
them paid attention to what they needed
and took care of it it didn't take any
more money to do it it's throwing money
at a kid doesn't help that child get
what he wants what he wants us to be
able to learn what we do is we have
these great lobbyists and we have these
great unions and we have these great
bureaucrats
and all of them are getting a ton of
money but that's not getting to our kids
it's not sitting down with them
addressing what they need and finding
out how we can better teach them it's a
matter of discipline on the part of the
students and teaching them personal
responsibility but it's a matter of
disciplining the government as well and
teaching us that money doesn't solve a
problem when I worked with Bill Brock in
his primary I got to go down into the
worst city in Baltimore the worst area
in Baltimore and talk to a couple of
kids at a height about five kids at a
high school which is considered the most
dangerous in the area and they're in a
program called the National Academy
Foundation it's a school within a school
it's something Bill Brock an American
Express bill Brock was a sort of the
president of it and American Express had
put together not paid for by the
government it's a school where these
kids had learned
turned the values and education of the
law they knew inside and out the law
they were debating court cases they were
sitting there these are kids that are
supposedly lost lost to the education
system they were talking about rifts and
tariffs and things that I couldn't
understand because they had been given
the opportunity they were told you can
be in this program will give you this
higher education there was another one
that debated the stock market and they
had actually predicted the stock market
successfully for a year and that was
their job I can't balance my checkbook
these kids were able to pick you know
mutual funds and stocks that would be
successful
the reason was somebody went down and
paid attention to them somebody pulled
them out and said we'll give you this
opportunity the rules are you have to
come to school in a suit
you have to stay after school for four
extra hours a day you have to be
disciplined you can't miss one class
they had rules if they didn't get the
rules they were out we asked these kids
you know why do you do it it seems
really hard and they said because I'm
gonna make something of myself well you
know everybody forgets you you know
you're gonna why don't we'll just give
you more money and you can go to the
regular classes no we want some
discipline we like the discipline aspect
of it I'm learning something and the
most eloquent moment was when I asked
one of the little girls DeeDee who said
every morning when I get up I hug my
mother cuz I'm not sure if I'm gonna see
her at the end of the day that's how
dangerous it is where we live but every
day when I go into class I think that's
not the way it's gonna be with my kid
this girl little girl has no money this
little girl has no sort of hope if you
look at the federal government tossing
money at her but where she got her hope
was that she was disciplined she was
given an opportunity in school and it
didn't come from the government and she
can see a way out that's a that's a way
to approach things we just get really
lazy we think that that if we send money
down everything's gonna be okay but you
know as I left the little girl said to
me and two of them said to me well would
you tell mr. brach that we'd really like
to meet him we don't want you to come
down here in a political cycle take our
picture put us on TV and then forget
about us and I regale this - bill brach
and he got in his car and drove down
there and
with them for two and a half hours and
talked with them and stays in touch with
them to this day the point was they
didn't want us to send money they didn't
want us to send programs they wanted us
to pay attention and paying attention
requires discipline and time and that
those are things you can't buy those are
things you don't get from education
bureaucrats those are things the
teachers unions aren't spending time on
you need to spend more time and more
energy it doesn't cost anything more
actually Dan I think you wanted to
respond quickly thank you
many of those things I agree with it is
important to spend more time in there
there are a lot of things we need to do
to improve our educational system but
the fact of the matter is if you want to
go to college in this country it costs
money and it cost a lot of money and
where are you going to go to to be able
to afford that most people turn to the
federal government to get some kind of a
student loan if the Republican budget
proposals go into effect each student
could be paying as much as forty-nine
hundred dollars in addition to what
they're paying now for those that are
dependent upon student loans and I think
it's one thing to say oh the federal
government shouldn't be involved in
education and don't throw money at this
problem that's not the solution but the
fact of the matter is if you want to go
to college you're going to need a
student loan for most people that's the
case and they turn to the federal
government for that actually I think
everyone could once again come in again
but we're going to move on quickly with
so that we can get to the audience but
I'm going to take a moderators priority
of just to say two things one is if
someone had mentioned the the programs
to help the disabled which interestingly
for myself personally when I was a
student myself I was in a serious car
accident I spent most of a year in a
wheelchair and for me the biggest
education issue that the government ever
did for me in my entire life was to make
rooms handicap accessible so that I
could get to class when I was in a
wheelchair and unfortunately most of the
buildings were so old that I couldn't
even get into my class and I remember as
a student very very well what it was
like to go to midterm exams in my
wheelchair having not been to a single
class for that course
not even one class the entire up until
the midterm because I literally
physically could not get into the
building and that for me that's a very
very important but not expensive and not
within the education department budget
thing that you can do for students to
make them have an ability to learn so
the whole dynamics and the interplay of
Education I mean Ann was talking about
what the students have to deal with and
what the teachers have to deal with I
mean one of the things that people can
do to help education be better is if
since one out of three families 103
families in my state at least deal with
deadbeats who aren't paying child
support and when they have no income
coming in at the home and there so
struggling to make it and the kids don't
have enough food in their bellies or
quite the clothes that they wanted to
wear so that they wouldn't be made fun
of in school that it's harder for that
student to concentrate because maybe
that mother at home is working a second
or third job and can't be at home with
that mother to help with that child to
help with the homework that these are
the sorts of issues that no matter what
you do in politics there is nothing that
exists in a vacuum it is all an
interplay between the crime and between
the education and between whatever we do
to make people's lives better which is
how we're going to move on to our next
topic which is the overall biggest thing
because there is nothing that you can do
in the government without some money to
pay for it somehow and I was taught
early in life that you can tell what a
person's priorities are by looking at
their wallet and you know there are a
lot of people that used to tease because
people would say oh I care about the
environment or I care about women's
issues or I care about my religious
institution and I remember my parents
saying to me well have they given to
them is there a check stub in their
checkbook that shows they have donated
to that cause because so often people
are very big on on talk and less good
about actual giving even in their own
personal lives not to mention the
government so I want to turn directly to
the budget and this is my last question
for the panelists because I very much
want the audience to have a chance to
ask questions April I'm going to ask you
because I know you've been working hard
on the budget issues
what is it that you see as the ultimate
goal of this this budget and how do you
think it will affect our families well I
think the ultimate goal of this budget
is that the federal government would
stop mortgaging our children's future
spending has been out of control for the
past 40 years and we've seen what was
originally good intentioned programs
such as the welfare system become not a
trampoline for people to springboard
into productive life but rather I've
heard a lot of people refer to it as a
hammock I think that our general
philosophy in Congress in trying to
develop goals for the budget is asking
some very basic questions are the
programs that are here still useful are
they duplicated are they duplicated and
are they wasteful and we've gone through
line by line item by item and looked at
every program and re-evaluated setting
priorities one comment I wanted to make
in addition to what you said is while
it's true that you can tell what a
person's priorities are by the way they
spend their money you can also tell what
their priorities are by the way they
spend their time and I think that one of
the unique considerations we have at a
federal level and considering vegetarian
matters is what is the role of the
federal government in some cases there
may be very important priorities that
need to be addressed on a state level
and so you can't look at the federal
government and say this is you know that
if there are some things missing that
it's not a priority it's just that we
think that state and local lawmakers are
better able to determine where those
funds go Chris
I think the budgets gonna be a very
interesting issue for a number of
reasons but I think a larger issue is it
is it's the chance for us to draw a line
in the sand about the role of government
and to have a larger debate about what's
the proper role of government and I
think the Republicans are saying you
know let's scale this back it's become
unwieldy and it's become unresponsive
President Clinton I understand is
getting ready to release a budget this
month
next month and he has an opportunity to
enter that debate about the role of
government I mean he may choose not to
do that he may choose to say item by
item I'm gonna fight you on these issues
and I actually think that that's lacking
courage and I think the Republicans have
had the uncommon courage to say look
everything's on the table
I think the Medicare issue is a very
good illustration of this I mean when
you look at polls obviously people are
very concerned about the deficit they
want to reduce the deficit but Medicare
and Social Security are the sacred
pillars I mean they don't want to reduce
the deficit if you have to touch
Medicare or Social Security and I think
the Republicans have had the uncommon
courage to say look let's face reality
here by the year 2002 whether we do
something or not Medicare is going to be
bunk we're gonna have some serious
problems and I think it's irresponsible
to not address that now obviously nobody
wants to take on seniors in this country
but I don't know that this is gonna
happen but I think we need to have a
debate about it on this and I think as
you said we need to talk about it in
terms of you know everyone's got to give
something here and it's our children and
I think Republicans need to do a better
job of becoming a little less academic
about this issue and a little more real
I mean every issue crime education even
the budget has the potential to be much
more powerful if it's cast in a more
real and personal way and you know I
think we can say to our seniors we
respect you but but you know fair's fair
and we need to not I mean it's our
children and I think we need to use the
opportunity on the budget to talk about
the children and not lose on an issue
like I think we did on the school lunch
issue and we failed to talk about the
children
enough and I just think we absolutely
have an opportunity there but it'll be
interesting to see if this leads into
kind of a more general debate about the
role of government because I think most
people want to see the role of
government scaled back and they want to
see things a little more effective Diane
I'm looking for you for a lot of
substance because you're the only one
who worked on a budget committee amongst
our groups so what are your comments on
the budget well I think when you said
earlier that a budget reflects the
priorities of its people I think that
that is absolutely true and I think that
the budget that the Republicans have
proposed certainly reflects their
priorities and their priorities seem to
be according to their budget largest
cuts in Medicare in history largest cuts
in education in history raising the
taxes on the working poor people who
earn $28,000 or less for a family of
four who get a tax break who work
raising taxes on them and what for to
what end well as Newt Gingrich says the
crown jewel is the tax cut and this tax
cut is targeted at the wealthy there's
no other way I mean that is just
absolutely the fact in there in the
Republican tax cut the the top 1% of
wage earners in this country the
wealthiest 1% would get to a twenty
thousand dollar tax cut I think that
Democrats feel basically this is not
fair this is not good budgeting these
are not the appropriate priorities for
this country and yes we believe in
deficit reduction we've had six hundred
billion dollars in deficit reduction
over the last two years led by President
Clinton without the help of any
Republicans so you know let's keep
moving in that direction but let's do it
fairly and let's not do this Robin Hood
and reverse a tax cut that benefits the
wealthy at the expense of the middle
class and and working people and I know
you'll want to respond
Dyanne since you're outnumbered I really
want to go gently so I feel I feel badly
about that but Diane I don't know what
budget you're talking about didn't care
any or what tax cut you're talking about
because it doesn't bear resemblance to
what Republicans are proposing if you're
talking about a $500 per child tax
credit that's hardly targeted and it you
have to make under a certain amount
that's hardly targeted to the the
wealthy and that hardly doesn't that
does help the working poor as well if
they have children frankly you know
again the class warfare argument of
Republicans are only for tax cuts for
the wealthy it doesn't hold water if you
look at where the tax cuts are targeted
even the capital gains tax cut is going
to help really the middle class more
than anybody else I mean people over the
White House need to take a look at who
actually benefits from capital gains it
is not just the wealthy it is it is a
wide array and especially the middle
class the majority of the benefit goes
to the middle class but this constantly
saying that we're balancing also on
Medicare balancing Medicare on the backs
of the poor and and this and that
Medicare and and the the steps being
taken in Medicare reform have to happen
whether there's a tax cut or not it is
not a matter of making the reforms to
Medicare to be able to afford a tax cut
they have to happen regardless
Republicans cut additional programs in
order to justify a tax cut so again the
whole comparison of Medicare is is
totally spurious as well I think what
you have to say is yes President Clinton
in the first two years did so show some
courage in helping cut the rate of
increase in the budget he did actually
proposed budgets that would cut the rate
of increase in the deficit Ronald Reagan
tried to do that and he did in 1981
proposed those kind of heavy budget cuts
and you would have thought that he was
taking poor people and young people out
in the streets and publicly flogging
them and beating them and throwing them
into the poorhouse when he tried to do
it when Clinton did it he was hailed as
a conquering hero and that's great and
that you know we're at a point I guess
when everybody was ready to accept the
budget had to be balanced had
fortunately this year he chose to be
missing in action
and the budget that he originally
proposed in Christine he already
proposed a budget had no
deficit-reduction at all it was
basically deficit neutral if not a
deficit increase and basically sat back
and said okay Republicans you guys say
you want a balanced budget amendment you
say you want to balance the budget you
do it they did it and again you would
have thought Republicans we're taking
poor people and young people and
children out in the streets and and
we're going to publicly flogged them and
flail them and kill them and all all the
most horrible things you can think of
but Republicans understand something
very basic and that is when money is put
through the government it is less
efficiently spent in fact economists
that retired from the Federal Reserve
Board did a study over the government
they came up with something called the
bureaucratic rule of two and that is if
it costs fifty cents of the private
sector to do it it will cost a dollar
when government does it so we understand
the more you can take it out of the
hands of the government and put it back
into the private sector for different
services to be provided the more you can
contract out the more you can send the
money back down to the local area to be
spent the more likely you'll have a more
efficient spending of the money and it
isn't necessarily and we should stop
playing the game of trying to impugn
people's motives of spending money
Republicans don't want to throw people
in the street Republicans don't want to
stop educating people publicans don't
want the senior citizens to to suffer we
just see a different role of government
in affecting the same kind of outcome
and we see a different role of money in
affecting the same kind of outcome so
let's stop the name-calling let's start
working together for a budget that's
going to help the country
Kilian you worked not only on the
contract with America but you were
associated with Jack Kemp and
supply-side stuff so how do you feel
about this budget and what it means this
budget the Republican budget that's
currently on the table reminds me of
something that I realized about five
years ago on my personal life which is
adult life is all about priorities and
tough decisions and Congress I think has
masqueraded for a long time the federal
government has masqueraded for a long
time as tough decision makers working
for the people when in fact the
out-of-control spending is recognized by
the American people as being a slap if
not if not a sucker punch in the face to
them
and so at last we have I think a lot of
the components that were talked about in
the 80s and and to a large extent
we're implemented in the 80s come to the
legislative body start making real
courageous cuts it's about political
courage it's also about moral courage as
well because many people think it is
absolutely imperative to cut some of
these programs and I don't mind using
the word cut because people I think out
there are smart enough to realize that
if you're going to engage in class
warfare if you're going to engage an
immediate test of is it a cut is it an
increase in spending is it this is it
that this is what they want done they
know that certain programs aren't going
to be abolished they just want them
streamlined and if that's what it takes
that's what they're looking for this
budget is very future looking which I
think sets it apart from other economic
agenda that have been proposed in the
past it's very future looking it does
look at our children and it doesn't
shaft the seniors by the way in the
meantime President Clinton didn't just
sit back when this budget was being
talked about
he sat back with a very important
document was released over a year ago
called the trustees report and it dealt
with Medicare and I think the American
people are starting to realize the
trustees Commission featured five
individuals perhaps six but three of
whom are Clinton cabinet appointees
three Clinton cabinet members a
Republican from the private sector and a
Democrat from the private sector and
they unequivocally Unitas Lee found that
if something is not done about Medicare
now it will go bankrupt that's it in the
year 2002 and under law when it goes
bankrupt it's over folks you don't you
don't steal from Peter and give to Paul
met Paul being Medicare unless you pass
other legislation President Clinton
chose to ignore that and now you hear
about not just class warfare but seniors
versus children versus the middle class
warfare and it's really not effective
because I think the American people are
smarter than that to believe everything
that they hear President Clinton needs
to get involved with the budget battle
because I think there's a fundamental
point being missed here Americans care
much more about what's going on with
this budget now than they do who
occupies the Oval Office in 1996 they
care much more about pocketbook issues
than they care
about who's going to be in the Oval
Office and it's there's time to get
involved so I think executive leadership
as well as legislative initiative to bat
to bind together as Ann has said and
work for all people there's a revolution
of foot here and it's very responsive
it's not an overhaul but it's a
revolution because it's fundamental and
it's meaningful and it's real this isn't
the time to run for office it's real
this is this is implementation time and
the revolution features a couple of
things among them cuts in spending
that's what people are clamoring for but
that doesn't mean that they don't want
tax cuts either and Newt Gingrich saying
that the tax cut provision of the
contract was its crown jewel was right
on it's like a five carat diamond to
most Americans because they like tax
cuts the flat tax is so popular now and
it's 17% for everyone I hear about it
everywhere everyone loves it if 17% for
everyone including the quote wealthy
whoever they are at this point and
people like the flat tax they don't mind
the fact that wealthy people as the
media deems them are as we deem them
will pay the same rate in income tax as
everyone else Kim well I'm gonna get
back to the discipline question and I
think our governments become this great
obese body and we're sucking down
slimfast pork shakes I mean nobody's
really getting the fact that you need to
kick back and say it's gonna take sweat
do I need discipline to say yeah we do
have to attack Medicare I mean Newt
Gingrich is our personal trainer he's
standing there saying you know what
we're not gonna we're not gonna get any
slimmer we're not gonna get any more
healthy if we don't start looking at
tough decisions and working hard out
there are you know the the Medicare
decision it can't be easy
it can't be an easy decision the wealth
fair decision the education decisions
they can't be easy
but the fact of the matter is year after
year budget after budget they've
exploded and they're out of control when
you have a welfare system that doesn't
let families stay together that
discourages people from working or that
doesn't say a job is better than selling
drugs when you have a Medicare system
that includes incredible amounts of
fraud that scares old people when you
say that you're going to take away their
money you've got to start looking at the
fact that there's a lot of fat that can
because now it's you know that's become
a political thing Oh
cutting the fat excuse me cutting the
fat means taking a little bit here and a
little bit there and that's not really
an answer but I think there's there's
discipline involved in everything and I
think what we've missed on a lot of
these programs and a lot of these issues
is the reason most people or countries
or places become obese is because
they've got a moral problem that they've
got an unanswered question in their
hearts or their souls and they we are
not addressing questions about why
people commit crimes instead we put more
money in the budget we put programs like
midnight basketball into a budget and we
say that'll take care of it why do
people commit crimes they're unhappy
they have problems they're mentally
unstable we're not answering why people
can't be disciplined on a welfare system
maybe because we haven't we've made it a
little bit too easy to be on welfare we
got to start talking about tougher
questions answer some of our social
questions and our social problems see
what we can do ourselves come up with
some self-discipline some self
responsibility and and get tough and
start working out and maybe maybe not
expire in 2002 in in the interest of
equal time this is how we're going to
work questions the audience is going to
be asked to address the question to a
specific panelist and we're gonna ask
for only one panelist to respond because
if each of us up here responded if we be
here all day and wonders real-time
constraints however Diane is going to
have a chance to comment on each of
these questions because as our sole
Democrat on the panel it seems only fair
in equal time for her to get to to
really have both sides of this but I
think she want to make a quick comment I
just couldn't resist we talked I guess
it was Kim who just talked about cutting
the fat out of the budget and you know
it seems to me when you're trying to cut
the fat out of something if you if
you're trying to lose weight you don't
whack off an arm or a leg you know you
you you you you slim down little by
little and I think that's what President
Clinton's budgets have done we've we've
cut we've cut spending gradually and
that's what what the president tends to
do the other point I would just make
about the the crown jewels there's a lot
of talk about crown jewel
but I think the people that are gonna
benefit from this budget are those that
own and wear crown jewels to the
audience they're new they're requesting
jewelers yes sir
if you can wait for the c-span mic to
come over we're gonna start our next
panel in just a couple of minutes so I
see our panelists are here waiting but
thanks to your patience and we'll be
with you in just a moment yes sir thank
you sir okay I guess I'll direct my
question to an stone you mentioned
earlier about the $9,000 that was that's
for each individual student I'm this is
not higher education this is one through
12 I just want to start off I came from
a small rural Western and from western
Pennsylvania school and I graduated with
only 110 individuals we were one of the
we were really strapped for cash in my
school district to the point that
eighteen of our teachers were furloughed
raising our level students from 25 to 38
students per class and that hurt us
format dramatically because there was a
lack of funding not only from a national
level but say from a state level as well
and that is directly affecting my
education and how when I was brought up
in ninth and tenth and eleventh grade
because in 12th grade because I was
forced to have less individual learning
and and help with other professors and I
guess the second part of my question is
dealing with the entire pan I'm sorry
what was the question there well I'm
getting to it right here okay it's more
or less it's I'm gonna get to like what
are you're gonna what is gonna be done
with educational funding but the second
part is okay I just want to just finish
off real quick how many people here
received state received national funding
from say a Stafford alone or a Pell
Grant when you went to school the
University second state okay I am
currently receiving that first state
system for higher education I go to a
state school and here again the same
problem it's a state issue but it's also
a national issue we're not receiving the
funds that are available we're not
receiving the money that is necessary
and that well that might seem well you
know what does a national government
have to do
state government because that our
tuition dollars are being increased
we're gonna have to pay back our student
loans when we get out of school quicker
with a higher interest on that and
that's not fair to my generation or to
the generations coming afterwards and I
just find that it just seems like that
you mentioned that it's not a budget cut
with education money for student
Stafford loans and Pell grants and to
regular one through twelve but it is if
you look at it from the point from the
perspective is when you have a amount of
money that's allocated to the future for
education and then you cut back from
that that is a cut and it's it's hurting
my generation I'll try to make my answer
a little shorter than the question that
I think is in there bottom line is what
I'm saying is and yes you have to have
funding to a certain level what I'm
saying is we had the highest funding and
still nothing was going right in the
school system or very little was going
right in the school system and the point
was there's more to education than money
that money alone doesn't cut it I'm not
saying that you spend no money that was
my point at all also in terms of your
point about student loans and interest
rates and stuff like that the budget
gets balanced if we get our fiscal house
in order you're gonna see a lot of those
things go down I mean if if we are able
to have a balanced budget interest rates
are going to come down that's a very
positive thing that will happen and also
interestingly enough alan greenspan
supposedly in discussion with the
senator on the budget committee said
that he also felt a tax cut was very
necessary to stimulation in the economy
that spending cuts alone would not help
the economy so so much for that crown
jewel not being important no I'm sorry
Diane I would just echo what you said
that you know people like you are going
to be hurt by these budget cuts we we
the Democrats and in the Congress tried
to pass an amendment to take the money
from the the tax cut to the wealthy and
restore education funding the
Republicans voted it down so we're gonna
keep fighting and we're gonna keep
trying to put money back into these
important programs and I just make one
final point if if if Republicans really
want to do something to cut
federal spending what they can do is get
the line-item veto legislation which is
sitting bottled up in the Congress it's
passed both the House and Senate but but
the Republican leadership has not gotten
it out of conference they can get that
bill moving and get it to President
Clinton who will sign it and then will
have the authority to to line-by-line
cut back federal spending last question
from the audience and then we're going
to move on to our panel on presidential
politics yes sir
miss Reece is our Democrats can they do
they claim any leadership on the on the
budget issue at all I think it was 68
Democrats in the house didn't vote for
any budget not the Gephardt budget not
the Black Caucus budget president's
budget went down ninety nine to zero in
the Senate and even President Clinton is
backing off his original budget claiming
to are promising to come back with a new
one is there is there any leadership
there at all or they have abdicated
completely to the Republicans well
obviously I disagree with the premise of
your question I there is there has been
a lot of leadership and there continues
to be the 99 vote that you refer to was
was a political ploy and it was nothing
more than that what is leadership is two
years of deficit reduction to the tune
of six hundred billion dollars done by
President Clinton and the Democrats in
the Congress not one Republican voted
for any of those budgets so that all
that deficit reduction was done thanks
to the Democrats that's a lot of
leadership what is leadership is
proposing a health care reform plan that
would really attack runaway federal
spending the Republicans you know
obviously they they show that now all of
a sudden the Republicans are saying oh
my gosh there's a crisis in Medicare
well we were saying there was a crisis
last year where were they so there has
been a lot of leadership there will
continue to be more leadership and we
will continue to debate this obviously
and I'm